andrés va a haber una película que
comienza a las 19 horas con 45 minutos o
1945 y dura 90 minutos a qué hora
termina la película pausa en el vídeo y
ven si pueden responderlo por su cuenta
antes de resolverlos juntos muy bien lo
que vamos a hacer es establecer lo que
llamamos una línea de tiempo esta es
nuestra línea de tiempo digamos que aquí
están las 19 horas
aquí tenemos 20 horas y por acá tenemos
21 horas a qué hora comienza la película
nos dicen que comienza a las 19 horas 45
minutos aquí están las 19 horas 30
minutos a medio camino entre las 19
horas y las 20 horas y a medio camino
entre las 19 horas 30 minutos y las 20
horas tenemos 19 horas y 45 minutos aquí
tenemos las 19 horas y 45 minutos es en
este momento cuando comienza la película
y va a continuar durante 90 minutos así
que a qué hora termina
hay un par de formas en las que podemos
pensar en esto la forma en que yo lo
pienso es que toma 15 minutos llegar a
las 20 horas
aquí hay 15 minutos por lo que para las
20 horas
han pasado 15 minutos de la película
cuánto queda bueno 90 menos 15 son 75
restan a un 75 minutos
bueno 60 de esos 75 minutos nos llevan a
la siguiente hora de aquí acá tenemos
otros 60 minutos para llegar a la
siguiente hora hasta el momento han
pasado 75 minutos y quedan otros 15
minutos para completar los 90 minutos
por lo que tenemos otros 15 minutos
cuando termina la película como ven
comenzamos a las 19 45 con 15 minutos
llegamos a las 20 horas después de 60
minutos llegamos a las 21 horas por lo
que tenemos un total de 75 minutos y con
otros 15 minutos tenemos un total de 90
minutos por lo que la película termina
15 minutos después de las
21 horas o de la hora 21 o como quieran
pensar en ella esta hora de aquí va a
ser las 21 horas con 15 minutos o las 21
con 15 esta es la hora en la que termina
la película